(upbeat pop music)
(audience cheering)
♪ Out in the cold ♪
♪ Standing where the trees meet the road ♪
♪ This used to be our
favorite spot in this town ♪
♪ Memories with you and me ruin it now ♪
♪ Whoa, whoa, whoa ♪
♪ That's where we met ♪
♪ Like a winter dream and I bet ♪
♪ I wasn't the first,
and I won't be the last ♪
♪ Underneath that mistletoe,
you've been so bad ♪
♪ Whoa, whoa, whoa ♪
♪ You ruined all my favorite things ♪
♪ All my favorite things ♪
♪ But you won't take Christmas from me ♪
♪ I'll be hanging every
light I find in this house ♪
♪ Playing Christmas music so loud ♪
♪ This year Christmas
won't be quite so blue ♪
♪ And I'm gonna shout too
much and dance in the snow ♪
♪ Drink just enough to let us go ♪
♪ Christmas isn't canceled ♪
♪ Just you ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)